Many people think of science as
apolitical--concerned with facts, not
political views values or opinions. However, when it comes to science-based
policy and legislation, science no longer
seems unbiased. The prevalence of
opinions and biases in policy debates
has led countless members of the
scientific community to avoid policy
debates despite their ability to provide
helpful contributions.
However, science and politics are more
intertwined than most people realize.
Science helps lawmakers write policies
and regulations that affect our everyday
lives. At the same time, government shape
science through budgets, laws and
regulations. Using NASA, the National
Aeronautics and Space Administration, as
an example, let's walk through how our
federal policies have shaped research. In
2018, Congress provided NASA with an
annual operating budget of 16.5 billion dollars. Why did the federal
government invest so heavily in NASA's
research? First, public demand for
scientific research can strongly
influence politicians. Motivated by
increasing public concern, lawmakers have
funded research to investigate climate
change's causes and mitigate its effects. This research is closely tied to NASA's
work in outer space: satellites monitor
Earth's atmosphere, and solar panels,
which power most spacecraft, are an
emerging alternative to fossil fuels.
Congress also funds research because it
recognizes the potential for research to
have broad societal impacts in
unexpected ways. As a result, many
groundbreaking technologies, like GPS and
advanced prosthetic limbs, have their
roots in NASA technology. Second, global
competition and national security
concerns motivate federal funding for
NASA. The Space Race, which was one of the
many arenas in which the United States
and the Soviet Union fought the Cold War,
ushered in NASA's growth.
After the Soviet Union shocked the
United States by building Sputnik, the
world's first orbiting spacecraft, NASA's
successful moon landing in 1969 restored
national pride and garnered
international recognition. NASA has also
developed numerous military aviation
technologies, like composite materials,
fly-by-wire cockpits and wingtip
winglets, that were later adapted for
commercial aircraft. Government
priorities shift with time, and this is
reflected in NASA's budget.For example,
near the height of the Space Race in
1966, the fraction of the federal budget
dedicated to NASA was almost 10 times
as large as it is today. By contrast,
adjusted for today's dollars, the
National Institute of Health's budget
grew threefold between 1970 in 2005. Now,
let's examine how science influences
policy. Many beneficial laws, like the
Clean Air Act of 1970, have been the
result of scientific research, and
scientists are frequently consulted as
experts when bills are drafted.
Scientific research also serves as the
basis for entire federal institutions
like the Department of Energy, which
regulates nuclear material and funds
energy-related research. As we can see,
scientific research shapes policy and
vice-versa. Every generation has new
challenges that need scientific
solutions. Ensuring that our nation's
students are provided the education and
training to meet these challenges, both
through science and policy, is crucial to
the success of our nation and the world
you